foreign
Caster what's up Bridget
hey how you doing Dr John party and what
about you oh working awesome you should
you should get a job where you can party
at it
I would love a job where I could party
at work yeah podcaster dude I'm running
a scam here it's so good so good all
right so what's up
all right so
um
my boyfriend and I we live together and
um he's wonderful to me never treats me
badly
um but there's hold on hold on you're
gonna watch us on YouTube and you're
gonna see me just start laughing then
anytime somebody calls and says I'm in
love and they're so great then there's a
butt and then they end up not being so
great is that where we're headed well
well kind of and then when they answer
well then the answer is for sure for
sure all right tell me about him so it's
more of a situation where we're kind of
we're not on the same page about certain
things that to me are important so
basically he has this obsession with
buying clothes and shoes and all of
these things but he has no intentions of
like saving money for the future he's
thinking about the now and it drives me
crazy
um to kind of speak on that so he is
ADHD and he's very impulsive me too I
don't care okay go ahead
no so he's very impulsive
how I can work with him a little bit
more on these things and it's his money
so obviously I'm not going to get
involved in like why are you spending
money so on and so forth
um but it's something that's frustrating
for me because you know we have rings or
you know ready to get married
but I don't want to do that if I have to
constantly be concerned that he's not
planning for the future
um so so I need to be a better
girlfriend but he needs to be a better
boyfriend in the sense of listening to
me and and understanding where I'm
coming from just as I try to do for him
okay
um I'm gonna disagree with you on a
couple of things is that cool okay yeah
absolutely
um or I'll just say it this way you
can't fix him
you can't change him there's not a thing
that you haven't done that makes him go
oh you're right I spend money like an
idiot or I'm trying to present myself to
the world as a bro dude because I got
dope shoes and shirts and jackets like
um
that's not your responsibility one and
two you can't do anything about it
and you're entering into a marriage here
right y'all are really close you got
Rings you got all the stuff
it's so good you're figuring this out
now
okay there's one person on planet Earth
you can control that's you yeah
absolutely and you can control your
thoughts and your actions
my guess is you spent a ton of energy
wondering what you can say what you can
do how you can present all those things
to him
and what you haven't done is spent a lot
of energy on saying do I want to be
married to this for the rest of my life
right you haven't spent a lot of energy
setting up boundaries or you may have
never had the conversation that said
your spending scares me to death
and I am not interested in connecting
myself to a hot air balloon that hasn't
checked the gas tanks just want to keep
seeing how high we can go
and here's but hey Bridget you know this
so let me ask you a hard question
why do you think so little of yourself
like who told you that
nobody probably me no no no no no no you
I mean you you said you just need to be
a better girlfriend no
he used to be a grown man
you know what I mean that's true
yeah I feel like you know anytime I try
to have the money talk uh with him it
kind of goes south because he's working
on the baby stuff this has nothing to do
with money has nothing to do with money
this has to do with a guy that is still
a child
he thinks of himself like a child he
acts like a child and yeah he in his
defense
he thinks so little of himself
that he is continually searching for the
right pair of shoes and the right jacket
that's going to finally make him feel
whole and he will never find it
ever
he'll even lie to himself and say these
shoes are an investment
he'll lie to himself and say I'll be
able to resale this jacket
yeah he does
you know what I mean and that's him
trying to that's a prop up of a prop up
of a proper
now I've got too many shoes
I got way too many t-shirts so much so
that my wife has implemented some closet
rules she didn't tell me you need to
stop buying t-shirts she said in the
closet that we share it will have this
many clothing items in it on this side
and I'm just gonna randomly take the
other ones off that's her boundary right
and so ta-da
she's not owning the fact that like I I
can't John you buy too many t-shirts
she's not gonna that's that's my problem
to bear
I like buying band T-shirts I buy them
obsessively right too many
um but she says this is how he's gonna
be in the closet because I can't live
like this and here was the conversation
that convicted me
I feel overwhelmed when I walk into our
closet and I can't I can't we there's
there's I can't breathe there's too much
it's too crammed full
it's hard for me to do your laundry when
I can't fit the shirts up there and by
the way they all look the same they're
all just dumb black t-shirts with some
stupid band on all right
here's what she did though
she didn't come in after me about my
behavior she came and said she owned it
she used the word I this is how I feel
this is what your actions are doing to
me and I can't control your actions but
I can control my behavior and my
thoughts
and so my actions are going to be I'm
going to take the things out that make
me feel not well
right
and that means I'll give you one you can
be a better girlfriend you can be more
honest and you haven't been honest with
them
you can be way more clear
and you can be much more firm in your
boundaries
is that fair definitely that's that's
totally fair that's something that I I
struggle with because I think my
reactions to the actions that he takes
it's more of like a I get irritated and
respond to him in a negative way instead
of just being assertive and saying hey
this is this is what the plan is here
this is what we need to start and that's
that's how I know somebody told you that
because somewhere along the way you
picked up the narrative that your
feelings don't matter
or your feelings are stupid or you need
to put them in a drawer and your life
was about peacekeeping other making sure
everybody else is okay and what's
happening as you're entering into a
marriage is you realize I'm trying to
make him feel okay and your body is
screaming at you we're not safe
because this guy won't think past next
Tuesday when the shoes are released yeah
okay exactly right and you have you're
at a you're at a Crossroads here you can
do what millions and millions and
millions of men and women have done
which is take their bodies alarms and
shut them off you can have another drink
and another drink and another let's go
out well and I'm gonna shut them off you
can watch another Netflix series and
another series and buy another bed
spread and another runner for the living
room because that's going to be the one
that solves it
or
you can start for the first time looking
in the mirror and saying dude I'm
freaking Bridgette my feelings matter
when I'm not safe I'm not going to enter
into relationships or spaces where I'm
not safe
and I'm gonna for the people I love I'm
gonna be honest with them about my
feelings of being not safe
yeah I do need to start doing that
that's that's absolutely correct I'm
I've never really
been good at communicating that's
something all my life I've just been
really bad so here's what we're gonna do
we're going to start practice we're
gonna start practicing it's not a
character flaw okay you haven't had
Avenues to practice if you just walked
into a basketball gym and you never
picked up a ball and you started
shooting it you look like a weirdo it
wouldn't be fair to criticize you you've
never done it before like we're gonna
get you some coaching and then we're
going to teach you how to shoot and then
you got to practice shooting free throws
a lot and then in short order you're
going to catch on okay and your shot may
always not be pretty but you'll be able
to get the ball through the net and
that's what we're going for here you're
gonna start practicing communication and
that's how I would start the
conversation with him hey I've not told
you the truth
like we're thinking about getting
married and I haven't been fully honest
with you
so I'm gonna start saying my needs out
loud I'm gonna practice doing it and I'm
going to make a bunch of apologies I'm
gonna be nervous so don't freak out but
I'm gonna start speaking up my part of
my mind because I'm equal part in this
relationship too and I haven't been
honest with you the way you spend money
scares me to death
I'm not going to enter into a marriage
that is financially irresponsible from
day one
because money is one of the top things
that breaks marriages up but I'm not
going to enter into the marriage already
knowing that we're driving heading
straight into the ditch
so here's what I'm going to do for You
Bridget I'm going to send you
um I work here at Ramsey Solutions I'm
going to send you FPU for free for a
year
that's all the lessons all the stuff and
I want you all to watch them together
I'm also going to send you the every
dollar app
which is a budgeting tool
um I'm going to send it to you for free
for a year okay the premium one that
looks hooks up with your bank it's the
one we all use okay and here's what that
is it's a finance tool it is it's a
budgeting tool it is
but it's a marriage saver it's a
relationship saver because it forces
people to sit down or it's going to be a
relationship Ender too let's be honest
it forces you to sit down across a table
and say
do our actions line up with our values
am I safe in this relationship are we
being who we say we're being and if you
want to find out who somebody is look at
their calendar and look at their budget
look at their bank statement
so we're gonna this is gonna bring
everybody to the table we're gonna watch
these videos together as a couple and
you're gonna say this is important to me
and this matters and if my feeling safe
isn't more important than the latest Air
Jordan release that's cool you're
grown-up you get to do that I'm out
I'm out
we're gonna sell the house and I'm gonna
go and I love you I'll probably always
love you
but just because I love you I mean I
gotta be married to you just because
I've liked being in a relationship we've
had some good times doesn't mean I'm
gonna hitch my wagon
to a wagon that's um there's no bolts on
the wheels things gonna fall off at some
point
hey you caught this thing early Bridget
and I'm proud of you you got a hard road
ahead of you some hard practicing some
hard conversations some some new skills
to learn
I think you can do it I think you can
come around
he just has to think you're more
valuable than a new shirt and some new
shoes